اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
بالاغلبيه قرارا يطلب فتوى محكمه العدل
الدوليه الى هاي بشان انتهاك اسرائيل
المستمر لحق الشعب الفلسطيني في تقرير
مصيده واعتمد القرار باغلبيه 87 صوتا
مقابل 26
وامتلائه 53 دوله عن التصويت ويطلب القرار
راي المحكمه بشان الاثار القانونيه في
انتهاك اسرائيل واحتلالها طويل الامد
للارض الفلسطينيه منذ عام 76
وتدابير رانيا لاحداث تغيير ديموغرافيه في
القدس الشرقيه وتغيير طابع المدينه
واعتماد تشريعات التمييزيه ضد الفلسطينيين
ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه والاسراليه نتبعها
من رام الله مع مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البودري اذا جيفارا ترحيب
فلسطيني وامتعاظ ورفض اسرائيلي لهذا
القرار
في اسرائيل حسن على كافه المستويات عاده
على اليوم هو السبت لا يكون هناك ردود فعل
ولكن الكثير من المقربين من رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده بنيامين نتنياهو
وصفوا القرار بانه وصلت عار بان القرار
ظالم لا شرعيه له حتى وصل الوصف بان
الرئيس الفلسطيني يمارس الارهاب الدولي
همم ارهاب دبلوماسي ويجب الثمن من هو
بالتالي نتوقع ان الجلسه الاولى للحكومه
الاسرائيليه يوم غدا ان يتطرق فيها نتانيا
هذا همم القرار بالطبع على المستوى
الفلسطيني بدايه حركه حماس اعتمرت انه
القرار ياتي ضمن القرارات الصادره منذ
سنوات طويله من الامم المتحده ولا يوجد
تفعيل لهذه القرارات على الارض بل اعتبرت
ان ذلك ضعف من قبل السلطه الفلسطينيه
بينما كل اركان القياده الفلسطينيه
والدبلوماسيه الفلسطينيه على راسها وزاره
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه التي عملت على الوصول
لهذا اليوم على مدار خمس سنوات من العمل
القانوني والقضائي وايضا خبراء قانونيين
وقضائيين الدوليين اعتبروا القرار بانه
انجاز وطني تاريخي مهم جدا حتى من قبل
المنظمات الدوليه الكبرى لان القرار في
اساسه لا يعتبر الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو
المهم هو الاهم هو تحويل كلمه الاحتلال
الى استعمار وعليه هناك سيكون ترتيبات
جديده في التعامل مع الشعب الفلسطيني من
دول العالم ان اعتبر من قبل المحكمه العدل
الدوليه كان نظام استعمار فهذا معناه انه
قوه فصل عنصري معناه وفقه الخبراء
القانونيين الدوليين بان ذلك تجفيف سيؤدي
الى تشفيف الدعم لاسرائيل رفع الحصانه عن
مسؤولين عسكريين وسياسيين همم اسرائيل ايه
اسرائيل لنا تفنيد الروايه الزائفه
لاسرائيل وبالتالي اعتبارها قوه فصل عنصري
والامر الاخير بانه من قبل همم المنظمات
الدوليه سيؤدي الى زلزله المنظومه
الاسرائيليه هذا لا زال بالطبع قرار يحتاج
الى المزيد من الجهد والعمل حتى يقوم همم
المسؤولين في المسؤولون في المحكمه العدل
الدوليه وهي اعلى هيئه قضائيه في العالم
بالدعوه ل همم
الدول تحديدا لدول لمنظمات الدوليه بتقديم
ما تعرف بالشهادات الشفويه والمكتوبه حول
كل فصول الفصل العنصري هنا في الاراضي
فلسطينيه ولكن بعض المراقبين يرون بان ان
تم تفعيل هذا القرار وبالفعل قبلت المحكمه
وهي الان اصبحت ملزمه بقبول القرار لانه
جاء من الجمع عمل للامم المتحده فهو يحتاج
لامرين شيء اخير حسن الامر الاول لا
استراتيجيه مقاومه على الارض والدعم
متواصل من كل الحركات الدوليه المناهضه
لاسرائيل
من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك